I think if I were Trump's press secretary,
the one thing I would not want to be is blindsided and
surprised. Um, and that's why I would never be Trump's press secretary.
[Inaudible].
I know you're not a, a spokesman for the conservative movement as a whole,
but do you think conservatives, um,
maybe had some branding issues over the years that I think are actually,
I think actually are melting away right now. I mean,
I think I'm probably evidence of it, you know,
when I go and you guys are all nice to me and I can talk and debate and all that
good stuff, but that for a long time, maybe just the word conservative,
it sounds kind of stodgy and old and it's like,
why would a young person want to be conservative? Um, that,
that actually some of that's actually changing right now.
Absolutely. But it comes everything cycles through the decades.
Um, you know, national review for me is my dad,
I think was a subscriber since I was a little kid. Um,
I think he voted for Goldwater, I believe that's right. And so I,
I just grew up in that world on a ranch and individual responsibility and
state's rights. That was super important to all of us,
but certainly things have changed. For example, I think, um,
conservatives for a long time were considered people who were against the gay
rights movement, um,
who were against gay marriage and over time.
And not that long a time, if you think about it in history over time,
that melted away.
And so that I think allowed for people to give conservatives
and a different look. But part of that is what are you comparing it to?
And if you are finding that you are out of sorts with
some of the nonsense on the left,
then you might take another look at conservatism and you look at somebody like,
um, uh, Dan Crenshaw, uh, the Congressman from Texas,
I did his podcast this morning. Um, he's a younger,
different kind of conservative. And then you see him on Saturday night,
live responding with grace and humor to Pete Davidson who had so,
um, you know, casually attacked him, um, mocking his war injury.
So there's a lot of great opportunity for conservatives, but
you know, it's a, it's a challenge, especially as you, Jen,
there's all these different ways to communicate now. So how do you get to, um,
your ideas to be persuasive for a larger amount of people?
Especially younger people. That's a challenge, but I, I think it's,
I think it's going better than some in the media might think it is.
Huh. Interesting. All right.
Now I'm going to ask you to put the press secretary cap on. So, uh,
I'll give you, I'll give you two things here. One,
if you were Trump's press secretary,
would you want more responsibility and want him to reign it in a little bit,
a little bit and to if you were Biden's press secretary, uh,
would you want him these live streams that are in my humble opinion coming off
pretty terribly.
I think if I were Trump's press secretary,
the one thing I would not want to be is blindsided and
surprised. Um, and that's why I would never be Trump's press secretary,
but I already had that job. They're never going to ask me, but you know,
I think that it's incredibly difficult to think about knowing an answer at
11.
O'clock giving that answer at 12 o'clock and having it undermined at 12:06 PM.
Um, but that is how he operates. Um, for some, some people love it.
Some people think it's horrible. Um,
the biding question is a little bit more difficult.
I don't know what I would do.
They are in a real fix right now because Joe Biden is now the presumptive
nominee. He's gotten no bang for that buck after Bernie Sanders dropped out,
everybody's sort of like, yeah, okay. Then buying and says,
I'm going to start my VP search. And we're like, Oh, okay,
well there's about 10 women that you might consider. So, Oh, well, I mean,
people are just so zeroed in on appropriately.
So the health of the nation and the economic health of the nation.
And I think that if Biden were to come out and push too hard against president
Trump right now and criticize the commander in chief and the time of a major,
not just a domestic crisis, a global crisis,
it would look like he was rooting for failure for the country.
So he's got to pick his spots very carefully and sharply.
And I just don't know if he's going to be able to do that.
Do you sense though,
that some in the media are rooting for the collapse of the
economy and just that they viewed this as, Oh, we,
we didn't get Trump on Russia. We didn't get Trump on Ukraine,
impeachment, blah, blah, blah. That this, you don't think so, huh?
No, I don't. I don't. I mean,
I consume a ton of news. Um, I'm not naive to the biases,
but there's a lot of problems out there. I mean,
I just meant like the food lines,
it's just the video you can see from overhead a three mile long car line
to get food in, um, Miami,
a six mile long car line to get food in San Antonio. I mean that,
those are just facts. Those are, those are happening.
And I don't think that they root for the failure.
They might root for president Trump to lose,
but I don't think that they root for failure for, for the peop for people.
I really don't.
Yeah. I hope you're right. I mean,
I see some people that are pretty mainstream voices that it's almost like they
just want this thing to continue.
Well, I mean, that was true during the financial crisis of 2008, right?
They were like, Oh no, but it was like,
well that if you didn't shore up the banks
and you ended up with something worse than the great depression,
what would have been the better choice. And again, presidents,
can't worry about that. President Trump has to again,
lift his gate and not worry about the headline of the day,
lift his gaze, look out.
People are going to judge this for years and years and years.
Forget about what they're going to say within the next 24 hours.
Are you making the best decisions with the information you have at the time on
behalf of the nation?
And can you defend that decision then that's a decision you should make.
You should defend it as much as you can and promote it, whatever you need to do,
but I wouldn't get so mired in, Oh,
they're against me because I think self-pity in politics is pretty pathetic and
pitiful and you just need to win that.
Just have to try harder to win the arguments. It's just takes a lot more effort.
That's why I always tell companies,
if you think you're going to have some problems,
always hire somebody that's worked in Republican politics or communications
because guaranteed they've had to work harder.
They've been through it once or twice. Yeah. Yeah. Do you think,
do you think that Trump, those sorta needs that in a way, like,
it's almost like him and Jim Mecosta are just like a match made in hell sort of
thing.
Like CNN needs it for eyeballs and Trump needs it because that's like sort of
what gives him juice.
It's a symbiotic relationship. Yeah.
The symbiotic relationship they feed off of each other. Um,
but I was watching a press conference recently and I could,
I heard myself saying, that's a ridiculous question. That's a dumb question.
But look, our founding fathers were really, really brilliant.
And the first amendment was first for a reason because it's most important.
So we have to safeguard it. And if they want to ask stupid questions,
that's so be it.
All right. I got two more for you.
And then I know you got to go do the five cause you do have it.
You do have a day job too. Uh, so one I've,
I've been joking for about two years. People always say to me, you know, Dave,
do you want, are you going to get into politics? And I always say, no,
but if Ben Shapiro becomes president,
I will be his press secretary. Is that crazy thing for me to say,
do you think that's a crazy thing?
I've never said this out loud, but I told Ben Shapiro,
if he becomes president, I would come be his chief of staff.
Well, I would be thrilled to work with you.
So maybe we are putting the pieces together here.
Oh, this is going to come back to bite us both. You know what?
We're going to begin those jobs in the soup.
Oh, just to see you thought you were going to get out and they pull you. Right.
That's so funny. I never said that out loud, but it's true.
All right. So that aside now, the really the most important thing,
where is Jasper and tell us about Jasper and let's see, Jasper.
Jasper is eight years old. He is here, Jennifer. Hey, can you come here? Come,
come.
Clyde always gets shy when I'm on your show.
So let's see if Jasper can show him.
So Jasper has been on TV a lot since he was a kid. Come on. Since he was a kids.
Um, since he was born, come up to say hi to your people.
Come on up. There we go. This is Jasper.
Oh, look at this. Look, wait, no, you're not going to do it. Come on,
look at Jasper. He's gorgeous. He's eight years old. Come on, Clyde.
What are you doing?
Oh, here's our.
Come on. There we go. All right. We're halfway there.
One of the things that I've found Dave is that Nope, come stay.
That dogs are a great equalizer. There's no politics at the dog park for me.
Um,
we all love our dogs and they gave us a lot of joy and um,
you know, whatever, love you, give them, you get back five times in return.
I'm so, so glad that you two plunged back in and rescued
Clyde. Um,
it makes me happy for you and your household and for Clyde in particular.
And I told you it, literally I had him, like,
he was like the second day I had him and I'm walking him down the street and
this guy who was my neighbor for years, who I've seen for years,
but never said hello to, he goes, Oh, that's Clyde.
I just saw him on Dana Perino show. So we're making the world a better place.
I love that. I really like getting to know you.
Yeah, same here. Well, thanks for, thanks for doing good work in,
in the midst of this craziness and showing people that you can be human and
still like politics and, uh, and taking good care of Jasper.
So have a great day.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.